hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the lendau gambit
trap i'm calling it the trap even though
it's an opening only because
your opponent essentially is falling for
a trap before you get to the game but
once you have the gambit it's an 80
plus win rate but we'll go ahead and get
into it and show you how it works so it
starts out with e4 and then we have the
karo khan with c6 we play d4 hey if they
don't want to counter the center we're
going to go ahead and take control of it
with e4 and then e5
usually they're just going to strike the
center that's the whole reason you play
c6 here is then to push forward with d5
maybe exchange but not give up one of
your central pawns here then we're gonna
play the tricky move bishop d3 now a lot
of people are just going to take on e4
that's fine we're going to exchange with
our bishop and be in a fine spot so if
you see that don't worry don't feel like
you're in a terrible situation but this
gambit is going to be looking at if they
play
knight f6 not the best move from them
but does seem logical
because yeah we could push forward e5
but then they just say hey we can we can
move our knights potentially coming to
e4 if they haven't studied it all that
often or they may just not recognize all
the threats that are coming in play that
we're going to be going over in this
video
but once they play f6 we're gonna play
e5
knight e4 not really a great option
because we have f3 and once we play f3
the knight's pretty much trapped it
can't come to g5 it's gonna fall to our
bishop it can't come back to f6 or d6
that's covered by our pawn also can't
come over here to c5 because of our
other pawn and you can see it's pretty
easy we have a couple options to take if
it comes to c3 so
knight 2 e4
not really an option so where does black
go well they could just come back to g8
that's one option another option is
coming down to
g4
you typically don't want to move your
knights multiple
times in the beginning of the game now
we could play h3 and then what do they
do they can't come back to
f6 here so they come back to h6 so
they've moved their knight three times
and it ends up on h6 not exactly where
they want to go and then we play knight
to f3 we castle on the king side you can
see we have strong central control or
just much better in all facets of the
game and they have a knight that's not
going to be involved in the game
anytime soon
so the most logical move if you're just
thinking about where a human might go is
the move knight to d7 it brings it back
towards the center of the board so it's
not over here on the h file
and it's also attacking the pawn yes and
knight's not going to just take the pawn
right away it is defended by the pawn on
d4 but this seems somewhat logical
and this is where
the landau game it comes into play
because we play pawn e 6 giving up this
pawn of material now as you'll see they
can't actually take the pawn and accept
the game but if they do
they automatically lose but this is why
i'm calling it a trap because they
essentially have to fall for the trap
before we can actually play the landau
gamut so when we play this e6 we're
hoping that they accept it if they
accept on e6 then we play queen h5 check
the only option they have to stop it is
g6 and then we have two ways to
checkmate one is queen takes on g6 and
they take and then we play bishop on
g6 checkmate the other option you can
probably guess we can
take with our bishop first
and then they take and then we recapture
but then you have to live with yourself
knowing that you could have sacrificed
your queen
and you didn't so the only logical
option is to sacrifice the queen they
take and then you take with your bishop
this is kind of a cool checkmate here
with bishop on g6 they have no way to
defend it with their knight on
d7 here
but knowing that they can't actually
take our pawn
then what did they end up doing okay
well they they need to go ahead and move
their knight it's under attack it would
wouldn't make a lot of sense if they did
not so they have a couple options they
could play knight to b6 and they could
play knight to
f6 for both options doesn't matter if
they come knight f6 or to b6 in both
scenarios we're going to take on f7
and check the king now the king should
always take the pawn on f7 if they don't
they're just going to be in a worse spot
and we're going to do the exact same
thing because we're playing knight to f3
either way the difference is
if they don't take our pawn they have to
worry about this pawn on f7 it's
blocking a lot of critical squares any
of the pieces coming here to e8 or g8
can't do that
and they still have to worry about the
knight coming to e5 checking the king
the king is also blocking out the light
square bishops that's just an absolutely
terrible move so the only other option
is to take on f7 but then we play knight
to f3 you can see the knight can easily
get involved it has an outpost on e5
checking the king can also come to g5 it
wants to check in the king
white's pr in a pretty safe spot and yes
there was a gambit
but they couldn't accept it and so we're
not down material in this gambit pretty
easy win for white we can castle on the
king side we can get our rook our queen
on the e file double up on the semi-open
file put a lot of pressure on our
opponent get our dark square bishop
involved into the game their king is in
no man's land they also can't get their
knight involved into the game because
they are playing the carl con why
they're doing that who knows so knight
to c6 is not an option they're really
going to be looking to play knight to a6
and then get it involved maybe to b4
because if they play knight to d7 right
away it does block off the light square
bishop they're in a world of hurt and
that's why if you actually get to play
this gambit you are going to have an
extremely high win percentage 80 plus
percent so that is the lambo gambit trap
definitely a fun little thing to try out
if you run up against the cairo khan
sometimes try that bishop to d3 and just
see what they do remember even if they
don't play knight two f6 you're not in a
bad spot you can always just take with
your bishop and you have a fine opening
here but if you ever do run into the
knight to f6
you have a pretty good chance of running
this trap on your opponent hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video thank you so
much for watching
let me know in the comments below if you
like these type of videos but thanks
again i'll see you in the next video
you